here on the WebEx app my name is Stuart
Creek I am a marketing manager here at
simply learn I'll be speaking with you
today about
the Caltech cloud computing boot camp
and
I do want to apologize in advance
because
co-host was unavoidably detained
so I will
need to do this on my own let me just
check to see if he's here nope
so what we're going to talk about uh
we're going to ask of course a few
questions about you during the course of
this presentation so please uh take a
look out for the polls that will come up
and if you are watching on the streaming
service you can put your answers in your
comment or chat's box
um if you're on WebEx don't leave this
is a full widget on Hangouts let me just
check have questions for me for the end
of the presentation please put those
into so what we're going to talk about
WebEx qna or into your streaming
services comment or chat
and we'll talk about cloud computing
careers we'll talk about what a cloud
Caltech boot camp is
we'll discuss some of the learner
outcomes
and then we'll share with you the steps
to enroll this is of interest to you and
then
q a Mike Yash unfortunately is not here
that he's unavoidably detained so I'm
going to
go on and talk about the careers
cloud computing
the as we know cloud is the backbone of
the digital economy it is the way that
information can be delivered
um from every source to every
desktop laptop
all of our hands around the world
without cloud computing we would not
have made it through the transition to
the work from home environment over the
course of this pandemic that's just
closing and so
it's a kind of a fortunate accident of
history that cloud computing existed
um
when
the pandemic started so
what we want to do is uh
talk about how cloud has transformed
Computing from systems where you had to
directly connect
to somebody's server to use their data
and their software
um
to now an environment where
this is all virtualized commoditized
it means it's
an extent democratized where small
companies can compete with larger
companies
um by providing scalable services
that can grow with demand at uh
economical
cost because they can't get virtual
servers from a data center
supported by the cloud rather than
having to build out a privately owned
data center as was the case in the past
um
same thing is true of
the computing power where you had to own
your own Mainframe in order to be able
to support larger and larger numbers of
users now you can
do that through virtualization and
containerization and you can
scale up to almost any size at any time
so along with software is services
Market
um
we're looking at a
20 or
120 billion dollar market actually much
larger in 2022
um we're looking at
several hundred billions
spent on cloud services
cloud is basically the infrastructure
that's going to support
every Enterprise
essentially going into the future so
it's a robust technology it's a durable
rear area it's where you can make a
great future for yourself
yeah
you have Cloud skills sorry here the
cloud skills open many career paths um
about architect
Cloud engineer developer
you can be a database administrator
um dealing with the intricacies of uh
distributed databases in the cloud cloud
security engineer
you can deal with the devops issues of
Distributing
software and controlling software
release over the cloud
so all of these aspects are
extremely important extremely lucrative
career paths
and you can choose to take your career
in any direction you want
be a cloud practitioner that you need to
have
really a set of skills that
comprehends the entire
model of the cloud of using the cloud of
deploying to the cloud of maintaining
the cloud administering Cloud
applications
understanding the
servers that you're going to be using
the data centers so you need to be able
to help your organization choose the
cloud provider you need to be able to
understand how to migrate applications
from other
platforms to a cloud-based platform you
need to understand how to do workload
management performance testing
understanding and security identity
access management
how to prevent
security intrusions in the cloud
you need to understand Auto scaling so
that um or
workload gets balanced and
handled no matter how many users happen
to slam your
uh site at any time you need to
understand the principles of data
Disaster Recovery
um which have some unique aspects when
your systems and data are distributed
uh you need to understand how your web
services and
applications will interact with your
Cloud systems
you need to understand how to migrate
um not just the applications but data
and all the other aspects of your
systems into the cloud and to run
continuous deployment
um
and so all of these aspects all of these
skills are very important
become a cloud practitioner
yeah
so that leads to our first question for
the audience which is
what has stopped you from becoming a
cloud computing expert today
you're all here to learn about a program
that will help you do that so how come
you haven't enrolled in program of this
type yet open the poll now
about 30 seconds to answer that
very good
I've got another 15 seconds you can pick
one two three or all four of these
reasons whichever one
been most significant to you
close the poll in just about five
seconds
all right so let me share their poll
results with our WebEx audience
um
half of the respondents have said they
don't have the Practical exposure
they need to become job ready
getting practical experience with cloud
computing has been difficult for them
um 40 can't find a comprehensive program
that covers all the kinds of skills we
talked about
um and about a third of the audience
said work schedule prevents them having
the time to do a program of this type so
let's talk about this program
and how it
deals with all of these questions for
you
so
the Caltech
cloud computing boot camp
run through the Caltech Center for
technology and management education
about which I'll speak in a little bit
more detail later
this is a six-month program and it
requires a time commitment of about 10
to 15 hours a week because uh as you'll
see it includes online live virtual
classrooms your expected to attend live
classes uh via your web browser every
week during that six months with some
breaks but that's a commitment you need
to make and then for the other work you
need to do you can do it 24 7 on your
own time on the platform because that's
available to you throughout the rest of
the week so
comprehensive curriculum we'll be
talking about how it covers all of the
Hill areas and various tools that um you
need to become
proficient as a cloud expert I will talk
about the integrated labs and the
Hands-On projects that you'll do
through the platform itself
you don't have to have a separate system
dedicated to this program all available
through your web browser and much of the
materials available through your mobile
device as well
um of online virtual classrooms as I
mentioned where you interact directly
with the instructor live you interact
with your peers in the classroom live
and this becomes your opportunity to
really get deep into the material get
direct answers to your questions so that
you come away from the class
understanding the concept that's been
taught
and as as I mentioned flexible so that
aside from the fixed
online live virtual classrooms
everything else you can do on your own
time on a 24x7 schedule whenever you
find the time watch videos while you're
in transit or do your projects late at
night or early in the morning all of
these are available to you so
what you earn at the end of it all is a
certificate from Caltech
this certifies that you have completed
the core courses of this curriculum
that you have demonstrated
your proficiency as a cloud computing
practitioner
and
along the way you will do a number of
different projects
including
Capstone project for the course
Capstone project is very important
because it's your final exam in the
course what it does is it ties together
all of the skills that you've learned
solving an industry-based problem so
that becomes something you can put in
your portfolio and show as your
experience with cloud computing to any
potential employer
if you're in a field that requires you
to do continuing education your employer
requires it or if you have a
professional license that needs to be
renewed you can earn up to 15 continuing
education units from Caltech through
this program
it also gives you access to the caltex
ctme circle which is a
Alumni Association for people who have
taken programs through the Caltech ctme
and
allows you to do industry networking
with those fellow alumni
something that you can
use
to come in order to find out what other
folks are doing learn from them get
access to their networks and
referrals to perhaps new jobs so
that's a valuable aspect you also get a
recognition at a convocation the one
coming up in fact later this month for
people who have completed this another
Caltech CTE programs and
that's an online convocation you can
actually send an invitation to your
friends and family to watch you get
honored
and recognized for your accomplishment
and last but not least
career assistance through simply
learning I will describe that in more
detail of debt
so again if you've got questions as they
occur to you please put them into either
the comments of your streaming service
or into the Q a box here on WebEx
let me talk about Caltech itself
of course we in popular culture we'd all
know about Caltech through
the TV show The Big Bang Theory
but Caltech is a real place
130 year old
University it focuses on research and
postgraduate studies so it's more for
people seeking phds than it is for
undergraduates
it has produced a number of different uh
Nobel Prize winners who've come out of
the school but also a number of Nobel
Prize winners have gone to teach and
research there so
it's a
one of the top five universities
worldwide and
ranking that you might see
it's the home of NASA's jet propulsion
Laboratory
those recognized as a center of
excellence and innovation
Aerospace and many other fields and
having that name on your resume is
really a an eye-catching accomplishment
that people will notice
so we're very proud here at simply learn
to be partnered with
Caltech on this program
um to be eligible for this program
you it's not as stringent as some of our
other programs
you can come from a non-programming
background and be successful in this
program
I do not need a bachelor's degree you
just need a high school diploma or
equivalent you must be at least 18 years
of age however
um and there is no work experience
requirement work experience is always
helpful
for succeeding in programs of this type
but it is not a prerequisite
uh
I am going to ask the question though to
get an idea who's in our audience today
um
and
how much experience do you have
asked that question now
so
we'll give you about 20 seconds to
answer this
I want to get a feel for who's in our
audience today
but we talk about this program
being open to people who are high school
graduates 18 years of age but the nice
thing about the program is that if you
are an experienced professional in
technology and you want to Pivot into
cloud computing this is an entirely
appropriate program for you let me share
with you
the poll results so
um the two largest groups of people in
the audience today are 43 percent who
have under two years of experience and
33 who have more than 10 years of
experience so uh for anywhere you are on
that Spectrum this is a valuable program
for acquiring cloud computing skills and
getting into that aspect or that area of
Technology
pull this down
on
we'll talk about how this program
prepares you
I'm going to talk about the learning
environment it's going to give you a
brief verbal tour
the learning environment we call our
learning management system uh
provides you with a way to manage your
curriculum
you
listing of all the classes uh courses
that comprise the boot camp it will show
you which one you're currently enrolled
running in
and only when you finish the current one
will you unlock access to the next one
it's a strict sequence
and it gives you uh
keeps you on track to make sure that you
are building your skills in a stepwise
fashion
the running management system includes
the live virtual classroom where you be
the instructor see the material they're
presenting watch their screen as they're
doing coding exercises that type of
thing
um it gives you the
environment to do your tests and your
labs
projects on a virtual environment as
part of the learning management system
so you don't have to go into a different
system or to a different platform do
your Hands-On work these exercises Labs
projects are all Hands-On
um you do the work you use the skills
directly
not just watching a video
nodding your head
um culminates in the Capstone project so
once you've finished all the core
courses in the program
you move on to a Capstone project which
can take three to four weeks
do that with your instructor as a mentor
and
you
apply all of the skills that you've
learned throughout the boot camp
what that gives you then is a final
project that shows how you solved a real
world problem
that goes into your permanent portfolio
show off but more moreover it acts as
your final exam for boot camp
so as you move through any certificates
you earn for each course get unlocked
and finally the final certificate for
the overall boot camp gets unlocked when
you complete the Capstone project along
the way you have support you have the
ability to ask your instructor questions
you have the ability to ask your peers
in the classes
pose a question to the community
on our community page you can also
contact our support Personnel simply
learned or available 24 7 to deal with
the two types of questions one is
questions about the course material
but also uh questions or issues that you
have in using the learning management
system so if you're up at 2 30 in the
morning using the system and get stuck
on something
you have people you can contact help get
you unstuck and moving on so
with that
I'll talk about the curriculum itself
and again we build the curriculum
on a step-by-step basis
that
starts at the bottom with an orientation
session
then moves on to the fundamentals of the
Amazon AWS cloud
on how to design applications and
architectures the AWS environment
and we add to that next
a second of the two most popular
platforms Azure or Microsoft
and show you how to implement on that
environment
we also then moved to more elaborate
infrastructure Solutions on the Azure
platform
and that completes the core set of
classes along the way you can take the
elective we
have a series of master classes offered
by Caltech ctme instructors on cloud
computing will give you perspective on
the industry on emerging trends that
type of thing so those are electives
that are no additional cost you can
choose to add as many of those as you
wish
and finally the Capstone project after
which
successfully complete
um the caption project you earn the boot
camp certificate
so
tools and platforms you'll learn there's
a number of different platforms you'll
learn the suite of tools from Amazon for
the AWS environment
creative tools from Microsoft for the
Azure environment
you'll
learn about containerization kubernetes
docker
so there's a number of different
tools and platforms that you not only
learn about but you learn how to use
through a Hands-On
labs and projects so that at the end of
the boot camp
you are able to put on your resume that
you have used these tools
know how they work so
that's always important because you only
want to put on your resume things that
you actually can claim to have used
know how to use
so
we return to the Capstone project
mentioned it about five times now but
it's really
one of the greatest parts of this boot
camp program because
it requires you to
choose a industry aligned problem
uh to
design your own solution to that and
Implement that solution
gives you the mentorship of one of your
instructors we'll meet with you weekly
to monitor your progress and maybe help
you out of any dead end you might be
falling into but it's your work
you do it you complete it and it becomes
part of your portfolio something that
you can cite when you're out there job
seeking and somebody asks what
experience do you have with cloud
computing
this is a really valuable part of this
program
global leaders the overall program
director for Caltech ctme is Rick Hefner
who has been in academic and Industrial
positions for over 40 years so he's
a seasoned veteran of Industry as well
as Academia and you're learning from
people Rick brings to this program the
knowledge of what industry requires from
program graduates what skills tools
experience
people in the industry need to see when
they're considering candidates for cloud
computing positions
um John wetch is only slightly less
experienced with over 30 years
um and uh he also
has a deep understanding of the cloud
aspect of Industry so he's the subject
matter expert who oversees the program
the instructors are all people who have
a background in industry or people who
have done this and for a living as well
as taught it so
uh you're learning Real World skills
how to apply them in real world
situations
John is one of the instructors who will
be doing
uh elective master classes
uh this is not
uh
Caltech branded simply learned program
it is a Caltech program that simply
learned the ports and provides the
infrastructure for
well I'd like to talk a little bit now
about our learner outcomes
people come to this program
from a variety of Industries it's not
just information technology or software
Finance
industry e-commerce
um these and so many other Industries
exist today because cloud computing
developed
the reason that Amazon developed AWS was
because
in order to provide Amazon
e-commerce Services worldwide it needed
to provide a platform that people could
access worldwide and that companies
could use to take their products
worldwide so they developed
the AWS Cloud platform Microsoft not to
be outdone and develop the azure Cloud
platform Google Google has its own
Google Cloud platform there are several
others
yeah AWS and Azure are the two big
but every industry now
requires an understanding of
Cloud because
this is supplanted this is replaced the
proprietary industry Networks
for example in the automotive industry
there had been a information exchange
standard
for bills of material invoices shipping
documents all the different classes of
document that need generated for the
supply chain for auto automotive parts
um
that now is all on the cloud so rather
than various computer systems having to
agree on a way to talk to each other
directly one-on-one
now it's all based on the cloud and
there's one uniform source for all of
this uh information to be exchanged
which simplifies things greatly for the
users
streamlines the process every industry
has an example of that
so you can see people who have said
their
employees to kind of program
people from IBM Microsoft Oracle
certainly delay Consulting Abbott
Pharmaceutical
Wells Fargo and Barclays and the finance
sector so
you'll be learning with a number of
peers from different organizations and
that's a great way to get additional
exposure to what's out there in the
industry
um we also have
I mentioned the career assisted services
from Simply learn
we work with a partner this is for a
program is designed for a U.S audience
and the the partner is a talent Inc
the our career assist Services work with
both Talent Inc for their aspects but
also the pieces stuff we learned
provides directly so we offer you access
to expert webinars and career events
free webinars uh similar to this one
where we bring in
industry experts we bring in experts on
Career management we bring experts on
technology
talk to you about uh different aspects
of
cloud computing and other Technologies
how to maintain your resume how to
conduct a job search various types of
things that help you manage your career
going forward
um we also include in this
uh boot camp the real world projects
that develop your skills along the lines
of what industry requires then the job
assist Services of course mentality Inc
very important
there's access to a job portal which
indicated
to uh
folks who are in the talent Inc service
pool it has the access to a certain set
of jobs that are
exclusive and it gives you a bit more
discretion in a job search than going on
to uh indeed or
dice where your resume might get seen by
your current employer
um
resume review and rewrite service the
top resume service is extremely
important
today because
before your resume ever lands in front
of a pair of human eyes it goes through
AI bot process that evaluates it based
on keywords and other content
understanding how to structure your
resume
be friendly to that AI process and what
content to put in in order to pass that
first level of automated screening is
Paramount importance to any job Seeker
today so
this resume resume rewriting Services
extremely valuable
gives you a couple of rounds of
revisions so that you get your resume
into the best shape not only to pass
through the automated system but then to
catch the tension of the human
evaluators who will see it afterward
and finally a one-on-one interview
service the one-on-one interview service
prepares you to do your in-person
interviews once your resume has been
noticed by our employer you've been
invited to talk to them they're going to
go through several rounds of interviews
for a technical
ambition
evaluating your technical strengths
evaluating your soft skills as a team
player your cultural fit with the
company the the interview prep service
gives you a chance to do virtual live
interviews with
repairs
is a great way to learn how to put your
best
foot forward in
in person interviews whether those are
physically in person or through
teleconference
finally
talked about the expert webinars
you can see here's an assortment these
are free these we're we're running at a
about
six or so a month
various topics and we'll keep you posted
on what they are
but you can get advice from people uh
who run job boards on how to use them
you can learn about new technology areas
and data science or blockchain
things about
uh using
certain technology principles or project
management principles to manage your
career so
that's all
valuable continuing education for free
and
during your program you're going to
develop different projects
these become part of your portfolio so
you might do one or more of these
projects in the blockchain program and
then be able to show off your solution
so
uh both getting the experience but also
being able to put this in your portfolio
and shut your employer's valuable career
support service
so we've done this
thumbnail of the
uh
fire program
and I want to ask
very briefly
is this something that you might be
interested in doing are you interested
in enrolling in this program based on
what you've heard so far
and I'll give you about 20 seconds to
answer that question
look at a couple other things here
and just a couple more seconds
So based on
based on what you've seen so far 96 of
you are interested in enrolling in the
program which is fantastic
let me share with you how that's done
enrollment steps
the the three steps for enrollment are
extremely simple contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net we administer the
program for Caltech
we will take your application or contact
us at ask us simplylearn.net the
learning counselors will
let you know what materials you need to
submit for your application
um then Caltech ctme will review those
materials verify that you're qualified
again this is not a stringent
set of prerequisites so it's uh
doesn't involve a lot of
evaluation and weeding out but they will
evaluate your
application qualifications
and then issue you an admission notice
at which point you can decide to take up
the program
the program cost
eight thousand dollars U.S and this is a
us-based program and pinned for a North
American and Latin American audience
um
the next welcome session actually starts
October 6th
so you can start right away because the
classes will start this weekend
and
to get started you want to go to ask us
at simplylearn.net you also might want
to check with your employer about
tuition reimbursement and whether they
will cover all or part of the cost of a
program of this type who are applying it
to your current work situations
a lot of employers do that some of them
will actually pay the fee up front most
of them will require you to pay it but
then reimburse you when you successfully
complete the program so definitely
ask that question of your employer and
of course you can Finance this uh zero
interest financing at seven hundred
dollars a month so that you're not
obligated to pay entire eight thousand
but what I also ask you to do is to
contact us at ask us at simply learn.net
make that a little more con for you I am
going to put into the
chat
that
email address as well as the
uh
URL of the home page of the program so
you can take a look at the program page
let me put that into the chat right now
you have that email address contact them
ask them about enrollment
um
with that I'm going to move on to the
questions and answers
I will
stop sharing the screen because you
don't need to stare at
that slide
I'm going to pull up from
q a box in the chat box
different questions and answers
uh let's get this one out of the way a
ball I asked to get a participation
certificate from the for this session we
don't issue a group of attendants for
our program previews we do however for
the other uh webinars I mentioned the
ongoing Career Development and
Technology education webinars we do
issue proof of attendance for those so
that's something to keep in mind
race is already enrolled thank you
Teresa
um
a denial asked whether we what would we
recommend devops or cloud computing and
that really the two things are very very
closely related but it really depends on
uh your personal passion
you're going to uh
if you're more interested in the
software engineering aspect
life cycle of software uh how it gets
developed tested deployed and maintained
um that's devops if you're interested in
how
uh systems are designed to work in a
distributed environment
setting up the infrastructure to support
that that's cloud computing so really
both of those options are great and we
offer Caltech boot camps in both areas
so
um
uh Timber trophy asks uh you're
interested in Rolling for this program
but you've already enrolled in the AWS
solution architect boot camp was simply
learned what I would advise is you
contact ask us to Simply learn
immediately and ask them that question
about whether something transferable how
you should approach that
that question because they may be able
to help you move from one program to the
other if that's uh really what you want
to do uh
almost almost asks uh is there a
discount for African countries the this
particular program is really oriented
towards the U.S audience so we don't
offer a discount for uh
other countries we do have other
programs that are designed uh for a
non-us audience I will say one thing at
present are
career assistance
available for U.S audiences and for
folks in India
we haven't implemented the career
assistance aspect of our program in
other countries but we are working on
that
um so if you do enroll understand that
that wouldn't be part of the experience
um
there's scholarship packages available
no the the
uh
extent of the financial
help is the zero interest financing
Samuel I'm already enrolled thank you
very much for that Samuel
um do live classes also get recorded
such as
yes live classes are recorded you have a
requirement to attend a certain
percentage of the classes live
can't just rely on the recordings so you
do have to make a commitment to show up
to the live classes on a regular basis
however
everybody knows that there's going to be
some times where you can't be available
that particular class session
so yes you will be able to refer to the
class recording and catch up on the
material but
really need to plan in this program to
commit to getting to most of the classes
live on the day they're held
um
and aren't asked the same same question
um the watching recordings that did not
count or the quote-unquote percentage of
attendance you do have to show up to a
certain number percentage of the live
classes however
um
you are able to cover any times you
missed
through the recordings
in a reasonable limit
will you learn about Cloud security as
well uh OG asks and yes Cloud security
is part of the curriculum
um
Teresa says I am currently enrolled in
the cloud computing program but I'm a
software engineer that I enroll in the
right course
um software engineers
certainly benefit from learning about
cloud computing because that's where
software ends up getting deployed today
most
outside of industrial control and other
things that nature but yes it's it's uh
if
you're interested in
how
applications can work in a distributed
environment absolutely
valuable to be a cloud computing course
and if that's your passion you're in the
right place you have other as I
mentioned earlier if you have other
passions relating to software
development
preferred the devops aspect you might
look at that as well but when is the
next cohort in November I would just
honey you take a look at the
um home page for the course uh it will
list
the upcoming cohorts
uh
Suresh asks us there's a course offered
by Caltech ctme on cloud architect this
that would be this program this program
will uh get you into the
subject matter and in the Practical
experience for being a cloud architect
so this is
um
it was a great program for that
um and as I mentioned around there are
devops programs uh you can ask our
learning counselors that ask us to
Simply learn Dot at
um
do we offer professional classes or
programs uh so our
our programs are designed to support you
in development as a professional
um
and
so they can take you uh very far into
the actual practice of different
technology Fields
um
so I'm not sure Samuel if that answers
your question but that's what I can
offer you and I would like to then take
a couple more questions here
um play says it's difficult to learn
solution videos that was an answer to
the poll question
that's exactly why we designed these
programs um Caltech works with us
because we provide a platform for them
to present live instruction
that
lets you interact with your uh
with your instructor with the other
people in your class then then it gives
you a platform on which you can do the
labs and projects directly
um that means that they're all in one
place they're all available for your
instructor to evaluate and grade
they all get tracked to your progress in
the course
in a non-technical student take this
program Omer asks Omer yes answer is yes
you do not have to have a technical
background you have to have
interest in technology and aptitude for
it
so that will be one of the questions
that people will ask evaluating your
application
um
so that you don't
get into a field that
actually doesn't interest you as a
career so that's the one
have you and I put on that but you do
not have to come in with a technical
background in class lab sessions
absolutely
uh uh playoffs we've already covered the
cost installment uh
um
clay s with 43 non-it or less than two
years experience this will make the
class very difficult for more technical
lab projects that's actually not the
case clay one of the great things about
the program is it includes the
foundational
courses that will take you uh
non-technical people and get them up to
speed be able to do the work so your
work will not be limited or impeded by
the capabilities of your classmates be
able to follow this and
do the best work that you can based on
your experience
do we offer sandbox trash
we offer a Sandbox where we can try out
some of the Azure services with no cost
yes that's what our live
lab
platform because it's a
Jupiter
lab environment where you have aspects
to AWS and Azure Services you can do
live work with them that's included in
the cost of the program
um
what type of entry level positions will
be likely able to get after the
completion of the program so talk about
some of the
the
positions I showed on that early slide
cloud computing engineer cloud computing
developer
um
be able to interview for cloud computing
architect and junior level there
um
and
you certainly you take a look at
Glassdoor or indeed or any of the other
public
fights talk about uh
available
positions and salaries in cloud
computing to get a pretty good idea of
what's out there and what's available
you would be
definitely qualified for the entry level
positions in that field
how is this different from the
postgraduate programming cloud computing
a good question Samson our postgraduate
program in Cloud
uh computing
is a somewhat different program
it doesn't have the access to the
Caltech
master classes or
all of that material covers a lot of
Fame skills but
not quite
Fame in terms of
the alignment with with the university
and
with some of the master classes and that
type of thing available so
you can take a look at the differences
and actually ask us at simplylearn.net
learning counselors about that
um
Ishmael asks a great question I'm
recently unemployed through State
unemployment the state employment
agencies pay for a program like this uh
that is something you have to ask your
States
Employment Agency
um
I can't answer that question for you
certainly
should ask that of your
State Employment agents
is this program a day program or an
evening program well I know and that'll
be the last question I see
here I think
um but
it is a weekend live class schedule
and anything else you do you can do
daytime evening the morning
um
on your way to work all of those other
aspects you can schedule around your
particular needs and your work and life
schedule so you do not have to um
worry if you end up taking a day job
non-it professional with 15 years
experience can I become a cloud engineer
Johnny yes that's uh if this is a field
that you want to get involved in
absolutely
um
kubernetes are Docker yes kubernetes and
Docker tools that are in this program
because
uh cloud computing requires
containerization so
um
that really covers all the questions we
have time for coming to the end of our
hour
I really want to thank everybody for
being here
I am going to um
go back and
ask one last poll question of our
audience
this last poll question
is
for those of you interested in this
program
how soon do you want to start
I'll give you about 20 seconds to answer
this but basically
you know the old saying is if it's
something worth doing
worth doing now
um so if this is something that you feel
is going to improve your career
open up a better salary a better
lifestyle for you uh
strongly consider that you start right
away
um if it's something that you can't do
right away for some reason I'll
understand that and we'll be here
to help you when you
try to make the choice so
almost half of the audience wants to get
started immediately
Freight and contact ask us
at simplylearn.net ask them about an
incentive to get into
this
cohort of the classes starting this
weekend so I suggest you email them
right away and again Ask
about the
incentive for lining up for this next
cohort the meantime
I want to thank again everyone for being
here
I want to
invite you into the simply learned in
Caltech learning community
and we hope that
marks the beginning of your journey into
cloud computing
my last uh
I think before I close this webinar is
to put into
the chat again one last time
the email address that you see on your
screen
as well as the
length of the
course home page with that
that concludes
our program preview today
thank you all for being here